is the sin squared of the same angle. And this makes sense
because the sin squared plus the cosine squared of
any angle is equal to one.
So our probabilities
sum to one as we expect.
And here is a plot of these probabilities as a function of theta.
To be clear, this is a plot of
the probabilities themselves as opposed to a plot depicting a single probability
distribution for instance.
For example, if theta
is equal to one half, then the probability that
we get the outcome one which is drawn in purple is equal to one
while the probability
to get the outcome zero, which is drawn in blue, is zero.
On the other hand, if theta is equal to one
quarter or three quarters, then we have that each of the two outcomes is equally likely.
And of course for all choices of theta, the sum of the probabilities is equal to one as we've already observed.
So we don't learn exactly what
theta is from this procedure, but it does give us some
information about theta.
And if we imagine a situation in which we're promised
that theta is equal to zero or theta is equal to one half, this procedure will tell us
exactly which one of the
two possibilities it is.
So that's a simple way that we can use the phase kickback phenomenon to learn something about the eigenvalue.
So how can we learn more
about the eigenvalue?
Well, this is a situation in which we can let
ignorance be our guide.
Because there really aren't
too many things that we can do.
We don't know much of anything
about the eigenvector sin, and we also don't know
much about the operation U.
We have a circuit for U, but for all we know it's
a horrible, confusing mess that we won't be able to make
any sense of by examining it.
But one natural option is to run the circuit multiple times.
In particular, we could try to do exactly the same thing that we just did, except that instead of applying just a single controlled U operation,
we apply that operation twice. Or we could apply it any number of times, but let's start with twice
just to see what happens.
Well, it's actually pretty
simple what happens. By applying the controlled
U operation twice, we're effectively just
squaring the eigenvalue
because it'll get kicked into
the phase of the top Qubit two times rather than just once.
And so when we think about
the outcome probabilities as a function of theta, we're essentially just
doubling the frequency.
For each possible choice of theta, the outcome probabilities
are the same as they would be if we doubled theta and then
took the fractional part
to get a number between zero and one.
For example, if theta
is equal to one half, then the eigenvalue is negative one.
So by applying U twice we're effectively squaring the eigenvalue and the result is the same as it would be for theta equals zero.
Which is that the probability
for the outcome zero, pictured in blue, is equal to one, and the probability for the outcome one, pictured in purple, is equal to zero.
This is very simple, but we can in fact get
some additional information about theta by doing this.
For example, if we know in advance that either theta is equal to zero or theta equals one quarter, then this circuit will reveal to us
which of the two possibilities it is.
On the other hand, we can no longer distinguish the case that theta is equal to zero from the case that theta equals one half.
So this procedure isn't strictly better than the one from before when
we had a single control U gate but by also running this circuit
we can gain additional information.
It's not immediately clear
how the additional information we can get by iterating the controlled U operation multiple times
can be reconciled with
the information we get by performing it just once, and in fact there are multiple
ways we could proceed.
For instance, there's a technique called iterative phase estimation, which involves running circuits like the ones that we've seen,
along with some minor variations on them, to come up with an approximation to theta.
But I'm gonna describe
what could be called a more traditional approach, where we use a single quantum circuit that has multiple control qubits
that control different
numbers of iterations of the unitary operation U.
First I'll describe how this
works for two control qubits and then a bit later we'll generalize it to more than two control qubits.
Here's a quantum circuit
that uses two control qubits.
The top control Qubit
controls a single U operation while the second from top
Qubit controls two copies of U.
So what we're doing is combining the two circuits that we saw previously, in a way that makes use of the single copy
of the eigenvector psi that we have.
You'll notice however
that the Hadamard gates after the controlled U
operations have been removed and there are no measurements yet.
What we're going to do is to
see how this circuit works and then we'll figure
out what we should do with the top two qubits
in order to learn as much as possible about the value theta that
we're trying to approximate.
After the Hadamard gates performed, we had the state that's
shown on the screen.